madame la ministre chargé des PME et du
commerce
on est tabasourdi c'est toute une vie
qui s'arrête ces mots ce sont les mots
des très nombreux commerces en piller
ces derniers jours partout en France je
souhaite ici au nom du groupe démocrate
porter leur voix la voix de ceux qui
sont le cœur de nos centres-villes de
nos Bourbourg de nos quartiers la
plupart d'entre eux souffraient déjà
souffraient de la désaffection liée à la
concurrence de concentration en
périphérie à laquelle s'ajoute celle de
la vente à distance puis il eut les
gilets jaunes et puis le covid enfin une
respiration une bouffée d'oxygène mais
non les saccages et pillages de ces
derniers jours sont venus ruiner le
gagne-pain de nos commerçants qui voient
à leur travail détruit anéanti sous
leurs yeux au final ce sont plus d'un
milliard d'euros de dégâts et quid de
l'impact sur le tourisme au début de
cette période estivale
en 2022 l'assurance multirisque perte
d'exploitation a augmenté de 10% en 2023
de 8% combien pour l'année prochaine
alors même que seul un commerce en sur
deux souscrit une assurance perte
d'exploitation sans parler des
franchises qu'il faudra payer
immédiatement des employés qu'il faut
payer à la fin du mois des aménagements
qu'il a fallu qu'il faudra encore payer
pour tenter de sécuriser toujours plus
ça devanture son commerce face à ce
désarroi profond l'État doit répondre
présent aussi madame la ministre comment
pouvons-nous prévoir l'accélération des
procédures de permis de reconstruire
pour les magasins détruits en effet
au-delà du soutien financier la rapidité
des réponses à apporter est essentielle
et il envahit évidemment de même du côté
des assureurs madame la ministre pour
toutes celles et ceux dont l'outil de
travail a été saccagé leur laissant un
sentiment de vie et d'oeuvre détruite
pouvez-vous nous détailler les mesures
que vous prendrez pour soutenir nos
commerçants et avant tout pour leur
permettre de travailler
c'est tout ce qu'il demande je vous
remercie